d'après nos merdes lauwers à travers de
porc l'a300 for peace passe et on
souffre et lampaul la mère de paul nous
fait l'honneur de reprendre son
personnage ses personnages favoris
il va nous faire un bâillon faible qu
est avec nous c'est parti si le bailleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
besson les yeux quand je vais pas mais
qui provient de venise avec un souvenir
qu'elle aura la queue entre les jambes
comme abandonnés comme soirée ce soir
malaga maillon faible
alors laurent se lance je crois que je
n'avais pas eu de phase ii seulement
chez nous si on arrive à faire 10 bonnes
réponses fois qu'un canot pour tout
public sector tu te sens l'ombre alors
vas-y tu débat par balles et gazés
chercher c'est parti conjuguer le verbe
savoir à la première personne de
l'imparfait du subjonctif baisse les
yeux encore at il fallu que c'est la
bonne réponse
attention au contenu vidéo ça va oui
comment les gens du voyage appelle-t-il
un autobus rempli cac
la caravane fallait savoir annoncions
rap avec angie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel footballeur français blond aux yeux
vos cheveux longs a marqué un but en
finale de la coupe du monde 98
la même taille que vous emmanuel petit
[Musique]
la science a beau se cogne convient-il
de bosses tient chameaux se cogne
combien tu es mort est quoi oui s'il se
cogne deux fois quatre fois les suivre
attention alors laurence attention je
rappelle que ce n'est pas avant
d'entonner un chant c'est bardé attend
appelle-t-on un élément fixe situé sur
le quai pour y amener un bateau une [ __ ]
ouais attention le manoir vous n'aurez
pas cette question trop facile pour vous
quand il commet comme quoi le hasard
fait bien les choses une vie d'alors
magma changer une lettre aux mots à nice
pour faire un autre mon anus
il y avait aussi à vis à vis one
attention vers berlin quels sont les 21e
et 22e lettres de l'alphabet fallait le
savoir
j'y vais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais tu m'as tu vu qu attend 10 paris
oui peut-on trouver dans la vitrine
d'une boulangerie dans le slip d'un
homme un gland
[Applaudissements]
on crie haro 2 qui soit calé dans sa
tournée loud rigoler quel moustachu
était à vos côtés pendant plusieurs
années ne rend pas bien bellemare y
avait aussi valérie bénaïm
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la planète
laurent comment s'appelle la phobie des
lapins lapinou phobie dacquois lapine of
black à la levrette la canicule c'est
pas ça quel type d'armes aphrodite
trouve t on ne sait pas très bien fait
attention on regarde dans les yeux à
faire passe rien quelle chose commune
arrive t on arrive à faire un
footballeur et un ouvrier du btp du jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui peut être pétanque de feu
ou de neige bull
oui laurence joseph raynaud maire de
lauwers travers de ponlat trois ans for
peace passe et on souffre et lampaul la
mère de paul comprenez bagarre quel est
le slogan de mnm ce qui peut également
s'appliquer à vos soirées coquines fond
dans la bouche
[Rires]
attention question rapidité qu'est ce
qu'un bonnet michel en marchant dans
comme la croyais qu'il fallait vite
parmi ces villes françaises qu'elles
n'existaient pas pour que très con où
j'ai pu nous ont fait perdre il ya bien
un mot sur ces 311 ketchup mayo que
potomac dans son kebab algérie oui oui
la jeune samouraï barbecue cyril de la
question quelque chose que vous n'en
avez jamais vos chroniqueurs parce que
vous êtes une grosse basse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]